we've done some simple code at this
point to load assets and resources than
memory but as our code base gets more
complex will quickly find that we need
additional power and flexibility to help
us get larger amounts of data into
memory for example what if you issue a
load of the same file multiple times
well each load will hit disk or it worse
the web and load that asset into memory
this can become a large performance
burden as each from disk fetch can have
performance costs as an improvement it
would be great once an asset has been
loaded to know if it's in memory already
so that we can return the in-memory
version rather than going back to
hitting the disk or the web multiple
times this concept starts us down the
path of an asset loading manager which
we'll cover in this unit now in contrast
to other languages which handle file i/o
as a synchronous or blocking
functionality all file i/o functions in
JavaScript are by definition
asynchronous as you already saw before
we specify a load function that is
called later once the image has been
loaded this is a benefit to javascript
because we don't have to put together
all the logic of communicating between
threads in order to load our assets
asynchronously giving html5 an edge in
terms of features for gaming